welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode i'm
joined by Bama lamb to break down how
Marvel could do Deadpool in the MCU we
know Ryan Reynolds has been in talks
with Marvel Studios but how is this all
going to go ahead is still quite up in
the air Deadpool is pretty much widely
regarded as an r-rated character at this
point and with scott derrickson
reportedly leaving Doctor Strange due to
the studio not wanting to go as dark as
the director wanted to it does seem like
we will be getting a tone back version
of the Merc with a mouth throughout this
video we're just going to be giving our
ideas on how we would do it and what the
best course of action to take is there
may be some spoilers here in regards to
the big elements of the MCU so if you
don't want anything ruined and I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown of how to do
Deadpool in the MCU okay so how the hell
did they do Deadpool in the MCU bubbeleh
I've got no idea I've got one theory and
it works like this you just do Deadpool
kills the Marvel Universe and you do a
reboot frutos at same time you know
alternative timeline we get to see him
interact with everyone thus killing
everyone and then probably find out it
was like a daydream or something but at
least we know he's in the same universe
because these characters exist and stuff
and it would just be the best way to be
like yeah look we understand the
Deadpool is gonna be abrasive and make a
massive impact let's just bring him in
in the biggest possible way do ya an
endgame did show like the multiverse it
did show that they have multiple
timelines going on at the same time I
obviously Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness is clearly hinting
that there's gonna be a multiverse in
the MCU and and I kind of like I have an
idea that Deadpool could actually just
kind of completely smash the fourth wall
and just kickstart the movie by like
having a montage like how he did at this
sort of Deadpool - but instead of
explaining like the plot of everything
just explain the Fox in Disney merger to
the camera
I was thinking like Kevin Feige could
appear on camera with him
I obviously Stanley's death there was a
big part of you know it's really rocked
the Marvel Universe especially because
he made so many cameos and so on and I
think Kevin Feige appearing as a cameo
in a Deadpool movie would just be a
massive massive thing to do and I was
also thinking they could do like
Deadpool binge watching the MCU yeah and
you know we could we did watch a cartoon
in which Deadpool had to interact with
spider-man and in that he compared
himself to spider-man and how he stole
his look and that would kind of I think
that you know him watching the MCU would
be a really good way to kind of show
that he's aware of these characters he's
poking fun at them
he's very self-aware that he's in a
Disney movie as well so I could see them
like swapping out the swear words with
things like fudge it and shoot instead
of [ __ ] like they could remember that
Osbourne's yeah yeah the beep but they
just had beeping all the time in that
yeah I think that like the beep was
always quite a funny thing so I think
they could like just have a beep over
every swear word and he could still
swear but it makes it more funny and
it's kid friendly as well kind of
pushing it to that at that place would
be pretty good breaking the for full
understanding that he he can't play by
the rules he wants to makes a very good
dynamic inside of all of that because
then that comes into how in he interacts
with people as well because then he can
call out you know like as Captain
America has evolved over time and we as
people and the audience elect he's
learning he's getting you know
look at him swearing now you know yeah
like you feel so proud of him and stuff
and I feel like Deadpool would be the
perfect voice for a lot of those kind of
things or at least the commentary on
Miss mess like you said what's happened
over all of that sort of time more like
as he's skipping through two channels he
sees spider-man he's like I don't know
what it is about this kid but I really
like his style
like in that core sort of just made
commentary for our all of it would be
really good and the question
like if I like you said throughout the
intro of like in the timely due to
credits you've bought into it yeah
exactly and I do think that they would
have to do a team-up movie
now the the episode we watched ultimate
spider-man season 2 episode 15 he teams
up with spider-man it is a called
ultimate Deadpool yeah just like
everything he jumps straight in and
changes the title name himself
Yente in it and he sort of goes on a
mission throughout well they trick
spider-man in it going on a mission to
get agent MacGuffin which sort of pokes
fun at the MCU in general because you
know before the Infinity stones sort of
got brought into infinity war it was
pretty much known that hey these movies
are just full of MacGuffins and I think
that would be the eye sight I think
Deadpool actually has the opportunity to
tell a laugh at the MCU
he's very cartoony especially in in the
ultimate spider-man episode which I
think the episodes a bit of a mess yeah
grevioux yeah like he has funny moments
where he can't say kill so he say zone
alive someone yep and they have they
have him doing some great crime stuff
that isn't as bad as shooting someone in
the head which is when he steals a jet
from Tony Stark and there are creative
things that they can show he's like you
know it's his world he can do what he
wants basically but without him going
over the top I would I would want him to
do some China jokes but I doubt you will
know the funny thing about that was they
were being very very like particular
about what they would have him joke
about and stuff and then yeah you know
I'm not gonna say kill so and so forth
and then towards the end he just froze
out a joke about being on the toilet
because the Indian food and I'm like
okay so so so we can just make a joke
about Indian people in their foods and
how it may affect you like body and
stuff and you'll be able tallit but like
he can't say kill cuz that would be on
you know Disney don't want him to be
that guy which I thought was a very very
telling of where their moral compasses
as far as getting fruits of children at
the very least I like the other thing is
for how he's doing the whole like kind
of green goblin like join me spider-man
like forget Nick Fury and joined forget
shield and stuff and I think that's like
that would be a good dynamic as well him
sort of being in it I like the idea of
him questioning someone like Peter
Parker's morals quite for our movie
would be pretty yeah so you know cuz he
is the Acne hero so I think you know
teaming him up with someone that is like
a Golden Boy would be a very good way to
bring him straight into it as well
because it's that interesting clash you
know it's the buddy cop kind of approach
and I think that there are these are
rumors and rumors often get blown out of
proportion and often turn out to be
untrue but though there is sort of a
rumor going around that he might be in
spider-man 3 now according to the rumors
a lot of mercenary characters are going
to be in the film
such as The Punisher who Disney are
apparently they've now got the rights
back to and behind the scenes so they're
trying to get him into that film
daredevil is also meant to appear in
spider-man 3 as Peter Parker's attorney
um and I think you know just see him
popping up maybe in the background of a
scene like on the roof sniping someone
as his first appearance just as
spider-man's like swinging through
through the New York that would be a
good way to just kind of hint then say
you know he's in this universe now like
a good thing that marble often do is
they'll set something up for in advance
like for example what kinda was in Iron
Man 2 and they're just good at laying
the groundwork so even just having him
do a cameo first before he makes a full
appearance teaming up I think that would
be a smart way to do it because it just
lets you know that these universes are
connected like the mobius trailer
dropped yesterday and that before the
vulture cameo I thought you know what
that little poster in the background
that's an OK way to to hint at the
larger universe without being like yeah
we are definitely connected now yeah
honestly honestly we are gonna come see
the movie please I love Saudis like
marketing technique like when you went
to go watch endgame right just to take
it away from everything I went to watch
n game they had Chris Hemsworth in about
4 men in black at
but before the movie had started well I
remember there was actually an interview
where Tom Holland interviewed Chris
Hemsworth and Chris Hemsworth was asking
Tom Holland questions about spider-man
and Tom Holland was asking Chris about
men and black but yes Sony now they've
now they've opened the doorway I feel
like every single 10 minutes we're just
gonna get like an MCU reference we're
gonna have like Iron Man just flying
around in the background of the scene
it's a cash grab now but the flipside is
do you even bother use Deadpool in the
main part of Marvel's universe
constantly or is he going to be part of
you know x-men's probably not going to
take place directly in the exact same
New York that everything has happened
you know see I think they will I think
they'll just reboot it whereas Deadpool
I think they'll keep it separate in an
alternate timeline like there are rumors
that the Loki show that's coming out on
Disney Plus that is going to revisit a
lot of elements of the MCU but it's
gonna be in an alternate timeline so
you're gonna see Loki travelling back to
like Thor the dark world
well endgame pretty much did it where
they went back to certain locations yeah
and Deadpool actually would be a good
way to revisit that as well like see how
Deadpool would handle you know the
invasion of New York in 2012 to see what
you would be like with the guardians of
the galaxy characters I think there is a
broad range of things they can do
but Deadpool is so fourth wall breaking
that you do kind of have to keep him
separate yeah um so yeah it is gonna be
difficult but I'm sure they've figured
it out obviously Ryan Reynolds is in
talks with Marvel right now it is
rumored that Deadpool 3 is gonna be the
third film that drops in 2022
we'll just see I don't know I would love
to get an r-rated Deadpool I don't think
we're gonna see Wolverine stabbing
someone in the chest like an x-men - no
I remember watching him in there oh [ __ ]
you just stabbed him in the chest I
remember I was sitting in the cinema
like damn what they should do is just do
a completely pg-13 Deadpool movie
no nothing bad in it and then in the
post-credits scene you just cut
someone's head off and then shoots it as
it falls the crap but to be fair to them
they cut off a noses head they love
beheading characters don't they yeah
like like I said at least we can get
maybe some mature themes out of these
they can be accessible without being
directly hey even in the kids cartoon
like one of the first things like that
we watch that spider-man says was like
I'm soaked to my webs which if you think
about it his webs are on the outside of
his suit so really he's just making a
metaphor saying he sucked down to his
neck as or whatever so there's always
room to put in things for adults as well
as have the kids like appease yeah I am
just looking at my blu-ray collection
right now and Venom is a 15 and Avengers
endgame is a 12 so there's not a massive
difference between the two um so yeah
we'll just see
now obviously we'd love to hear your
thoughts on how to do Deadpool in the
MCU so make sure you comment below and
let us know if you want to check out
Bama lambs channel where he does
breakdowns on your favorite movies TV
shows and more then make sure you click
the link right now or the link in the
description below you want something
else to watch then check out our
breakdown of how Mobius connects the MCU
which is gonna be linked after this we
go over all of the ins and outs of
what's gonna happen on screen and behind
the scenes so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
you can support the show by subscribing
to us on patreon and if you want to come
chat to us after the video either join
our discord server in the description or
follow us on twitter at definition
whitey that's the best way to keep up to
date with everything we do at heavy
spoilers and hopefully we see over there
very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]